it we've got plenty to discuss in the
national football league and we've got
new coaches we've got new coaches who
are first-time coaches who don't really
have an opportunity to install their
systems but one of the things we are
learning as it relates to the new york
giants
the
system that they use on offense may look
a lot like the system that has been in
use and will still be in use in dallas
here's joe judge first year coach of the
giants talking about the offense that
his team may be using with former
cowboys coach jason garrett as the
coordinator
i think schematically the easiest way to
describe it to kind of the outside world
right now is you know it's going to be
similarly based off what jason's done in
dallas over the last 10 or so years
so there's going to be some similarities
care to that but it's got to cater to
our players we have on our roster
currently
all right there he is joe judge
and this is the kind of thing that i
think would get giants fans to throw
soup at the tv like mickey and rocky too
i don't know that you want to publicize
to the world that you're going to use
the jason garrett offense because one of
the reasons jason garrett isn't the
coach in dallas anymore peter king is
because of the jason garrett offense
your thoughts
well i'll say this about the jason
garrett offense has been a lot more
productive than the new york giants
offense in the last
truth it's true
you know and so look i
you know if you're going to hire a coach
he's going to coach what he knows
now joe judge has never been an
offensive coordinator he's never been an
offensive minded guy
so
the question is whoever you hire
you know if you hired uh
you know if if you hire chan galey he's
probably going to do something that's a
lot like they had been doing in dallas
or pittsburgh or wherever he had been
so i don't criticize the giants for
doing that i would criticize the giants
for hiring jason garrett and saying whoa
whoa
you can't coach what you have been
coaching
you gotta go to a wide open run and
shoot now you know with four and five
wides every snap you're not doing that
you're gonna go to the guy's strengths
and they would not have hired jason
garrett if they thought he had a horse
crap offense the last few years in
dallas
yeah and that's right peter i mean
you're right they would not have you
know and did joe judge listen he he i'm
sure understands there you know when i
first read the comment or whatever i
said man he's got to be careful with
those type of comments knowing that the
fan base might be oh what jason
garrett's often stunk in dallas and all
those things now he tried to say you
know hey to the basic fan it's going to
look similar to dallas but i don't think
it's going to be what we saw the last
few years and the peter's point you know
too dallas's offense has been better
than i
that we give it credit for as a national
media or football fans or whatever it
may be i mean it was the number one
offense in football last year and i
think people forget that and of course
you know listen i know there were some
stale points or it was the number two
offense when my right of mine was one or
two i'm not one i'm running number one
in total yards
so when you look at that right and i and
i understand some of the criticism with
jason garrett's offense because there's
been some years where we go man there's
not a lot of motions and movements and
things like that but i also would say
jason garrett was not totally in charge
of the offense the last few years either
and we saw improvements he got rid of
scott lennon hand made a made a nice
move to get to kelvin moore
and then let's also not forget the fact
that jason garrett is going to be just
the offensive coordinator here for the
new york giants and jason garrett's you
know
you know street wrecker you know record
as an offensive coordinator is is pretty
damn good when you go back to his early
days in dallas when he left the miami
dolphins went to the cowboys was the
offensive coordinator then was the
offensive coordinator and play caller
hey the offense put up a lot of numbers
and points and yards all the time it
really did now when it came into a
problem is he mismanaged some games
because he was too worried about trying
to figure out the offensive plays and
then that's when you know he or jerry
jones kind of took the power away from
him so i think with jason garrett's
ability to kind of just hunker in on the
offense
you know i don't think giant fans should
be scared and to peter's point that
cowboy often has been a lot better than
that giant offense the last four or five
years that's for sure
yeah you know what that is an excellent
point and it's amazing the perception
out there conflicts so sharply with the
reality when i pulled up the rankings
from 2019 of all offenses i'm looking
for the cowboys somewhere below one or
two and it's like where are the cowboys
surely they were in the top half last
year dak prescott had 4 900 passing
yards ezekiel had 1300 rushing yards
they have to be in the top half and i
look up and there they are at the very
top 431.5
yards per game that's nearly 24 more
yards per game on average than the
number two offense in football last year
the baltimore ravens that is amazing now
they're number six in scoring the
cowboys were at 27.1 points per game
which still isn't bad
but i'm trying to reconcile why the
perception and the reality don't mesh
and i think part of the problem is and
chris you hit on it
early in his career jason garrett
demonstrated an inability to micromanage
the offense and macromanage the team and
he made bad decisions as the head coach
while focused on the play in and play
out grind of knowing what the next play
is going to be what's the next play
going to be this is something tony dungy
explained at the time and i recall this
vividly you have to be able to do both
things and if you can't do both things
stop doing both things and it took a
while but the cowboys eventually figured
out we can't let him do both things but
you know the problem is because the
cowboys hung on to jason garrett for so
long
instead of firing him they almost kind
of marginalized him they created this
perception
reputation that he's not a very good
coach peter and and i think the cowboys
keeping him longer than they should have
is one of the reasons now we view him as
broken in some way when the reality is
he may not be broken at all
i mean here's the way you gotta look at
jason garrett okay
so
the dallas cowboys in the last few years
as an organization and as a team on the
field underachieved now they've actually
drafted pretty well
haven't drafted peerlessly but they've
drafted pretty well okay
and
when that happens consistently year
after year you don't get to the promised
land
when you work for jerry jones eventually
that is going to cost you your job now
it was a long eventually in dallas
but again look i look at the way the
cowboys have played football
in the last four years
and basically this is a team that's
averaging about you know 390 points a
game
you know in the last four years or 390
points a season excuse me in the last
four years
and when i look at that that's all
that's going to be in the top 10
you know almost every year if you
average that and so to me
it wasn't the weakness of the offense
that got jason garrett fired it's
basically the mediocrity of the program
that got him fired
yeah i i would agree with that in a lot
of ways the overall look of jason
garrett and the perception that it sent
to the fans the media everything about
it you know one hey dallas cowboys
offense last year statistically yes it
was number one you you know you guys
know it wasn't the best offense in
football they it wasn't it's not better
than baltimore's it wasn't better than
the 49ers you know think about all the
games those teams didn't even play in
the fourth quarter because they blew
teams out dallas also last year let's
not forget you know got a lot of garbage
time yards whether it was the bears game
or a few other games and they feasted on
the week to a degree but within all of
that jason garrett is an extremely
intelligent human being and i think the
fact that you know the he'll understand
what is being talked about around him
and his situation and i think the fact
that he's going to be just the offensive
coordinator not have to worry about all
these other things
is going to make him
his ability to hunker down and be more
creative and try new things you know i
think that's going to be a bit a big
thing for him too but i think peter is
right and he's on to something and mike
you are too
you know it's it's the overall look like
you know it's the underwhelming big
moments oh 2018 they go to the playoffs
they win a playoff game wow yeah but
then they go to the rams and don't play
that well out there you know hey 2016
they're 13 and three and you're going
they're the best team in football
they're so dominant they let aaron
rodgers and the green bay packers come
into town and kind of wipe the floor
with them there and have those amazing
throws and you know they don't get to
the nfc championship game so i think
it's all of it a little bit that's been
thrown in on jason garrett and this
perception of him that he's less than as
an offense of mine
yeah i mean ultimately it comes down to
how many games you'll win and what you
do when the season is on the line this
is a team that continues to have a
drought in nfc championship game
appearances that goes back to 1995 and
last year for as good as the offense is
hey highest rated offense in football
from a yardage standpoint 8-8 as a
football team that's the problem and
that's why the cowboys eventually cut
the cord even if they did so a few years
too late so now that garrett takes over
in new york he's got daniel jones
as his primary pupil and that i don't
know the giants hope is an upgrade over
pat shurmur as the person developing
daniel jones peter what do we think
garrett can do
with
daniel jones when we acknowledge the
reality that jason garrett had to have
had a significant hand in the
development of a guy named dak prescott
who has become one of the better
quarterbacks in the nfl
i think there's two things that jason
garrett brings number one it is
exactly that over the last four years he
developed a mid-fourth round pick
into a top 10 quarterback in the nfl and
so if you look at some of the things he
did with dak prescott and then you look
at the skills that daniel jones has
the beneficiary of all this in my
opinion
is the new york giants offense because
jason garrett wants to coach a
quarterback who can move
if he came in and coached eli manning
i'm sure he would have done fine and
they would have been very productive but
he wants movement to be a part of his
of his offensive game for the
quarterback and number two
i think what you're going to see him do
much more than
the previous regime or regimes
is he's really going to try to get the
tight end more involved in this offense
he believes that you know
the tight end and running personnel that
and and look you see what you see around
the nfl right now with people continuing
to go
more and more wide receivers but
there are still there's still a cadre of
coaches around the nfl that wants to
have
three healthy tight ends on game day and
wants to run some formations with two
tights you look and see what matt nagy
did and i'm not calling him the you know
the greatest offensive coach in the
world either but
you know he was so concerned
last year with tight ends because they
had three tight ends on injured reserve
he's so concerned that he takes one with
their first pick in the draft he and
ryan pace so i'm saying that he's going
to have a quarterback who moves he's
going to use the tight end a little bit
more and now he's just got to hope that
the young wide receiving core is going
to develop into something approximating
what they had in dallas
well yeah and hey you know to echo that
a little bit i mean the nfl is kind of
going back right into the direction i
think of you know
jason garrett's uh you know what about
his generation of play calling to a
degree you know peter talks about hey
yeah there's certain teams dabbling in
the spread and more wide receivers but
you can also sit there and look at the
ravens the 49ers hey the tennessee
titans who we saw in the nfc
championship game the eagles the rams
they're very into running the football
and jason garrett and with this
offensive line that the the new york
giants you know have kind of retooled
here you know with saquon barkley he's
going gonna have some toys to play with
in the run game and then you know off of
what peter said with daniel jones daniel
jones from everything i saw last year i
mean it makes me
think he's got a chance to be really
special i mean he was the mvp of the
giants last year they put the game on
his shoulders more times than not with
the bad offensive line saquon not being
totally healthy at the running back
position it was kind of like hey daniel
we need you to drop back 40 times and
you got to throw three touchdowns and
one interceptions or we or we can't win
the game and he did that a number of
times i mean he really played phenomenal
with not big-time talent around him at
the wide receiver position i think jason
garrett really smart he's going to
formulate an offense that fits this this
the skill set of all these guys uh and
make the vision of the team under what
joe judge really wants it to be to be
successful
i want a five second answer from each of
you on this question as it relates to
the running back swap that jason garrett
has inherited ezekiel elliott saquon
barkley which one would you prefer peter
i'd rather have barkley because he's
just a little bit younger
i'd rather have barkley too barkley can
make more with less and barkley if
there's a chance to go 70 he can go 70.
so i'm taking barclay
yeah you know what i hate to say it
because i love ezekiel elliott but i
think saquon barkley's got a higher
ceiling and he's got more tread on the
tire
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports